so this talk I'm sorry my name is adam
smith i work at Penn State I'm on
sabbatical this year in Boston at vu
mostly and i'll be speaking about some
joy i'll be speaking about forward
stability privacy and online learning
this is based largely on paper i wrote
with a birdie that appeared at nips just
a few days ago but also based on
conversations well with a number of
people including a burr deep and
critique ok so we've seen various you
know connections along these lines in
particular in Aberdeen's talk earlier
this afternoon but in general if this
workshop and so I'd like to look at a
particular connection between privacy
and online learning and the notion of
stability that seems to be most relevant
there which is sort of something like
something called forward stability um
and a lot of what I'm going to say is
sort of stuff that is I guess implicit
in most cases in the online learning the
non private online learning online
learning literature but I'd like you to
give you kind of my my way of thinking
of it my take on it and hopefully this
will you know give you some insight into
how this set of algorithms works alright
so what's the problem we're looking at
imagine we've got we've got some
learning problem so we've got two sets x
and c to think of x is where the data
lives and see as the parameter space
that you're trying to learn something in
and and some loss function that takes a
pair of things and gives me a real
number and you've got this setting where
you've got this algorithm who's trying
to learn in this environment that's
trying to you know put obstacles in the
environment the algorithms way and
here's what happens we've played this
game for several rounds or at each round
the algorithm announces
well here's here's what I think the
parameter vector should be here's what I
think is going mine it this is my model
of the world the environment says well
here's some data and the algorithm pays
and it pays the loss of this prediction
on on on the data that was a that was
presented and whoa not my laptop yes
alright so okay so so we'll think of the
data so the data you know what the data
is can vary from application to
application but we'll sort of think of
the data is actually giving me a
function as a cost function okay so
normally we think of data is you know
strings and stuff like that and but
let's just think of it at the adversary
the environment produces a cost function
so this is you know just the loss
function with with the data fixed and so
what I pay is sort of first I make a
prediction then I see the cost function
and I pay this cost function applied in
my prediction okay so this seems like a
very difficult model for the algorithm
to live in because it has to make a
prediction for you know it's gonna pace
for something that hasn't yet seen in
the environment and in full generality
can make it can choose this empathy
based on the prediction that was made
but the the way we'll sort of make the
algorithms life easier is that we're
only interested in minimizing the
algorithms with regret with respect to
the best fix choice in hindsight ok so
the regret is this the costs i paid mine
is the best single parameter i could
have played with the whole time this is
one notion of regret there are several
others this is most prevalent one no
I can only go backwards okay so let's
start at the last lab so so some muscle
online learning problems i'm going to
talk about in fact i'll only mention one
non convex problem and i won't even get
into any details but essentially i'm
going to be talking about convex
learning problems where we're so both
the set C of available parameter choices
and the functions that are the cost
functions that I'm playing against these
are convex okay so an example would be
learning from experts which came up in
John's talk this morning here I'm my I
imagine my my W is a distribution over
experts okay so either the name of one
expert or maybe some convex combination
thereof and X is sort of the cost the
money lost by each of my impossible
investment advisors and you know what I
lose is the sort of the inner product of
these two things right the the money
lost by the investment advisor I chose
it this time least squares regression
fits into this median problems type type
problems fit in this frame where there
are lots of things that are comebacks I
don't think I've to belabor that point
so you know what are the kinds of
algorithms people use to solve this is
there's a large literature on that but
like let me give you two that two
different looking things that go on one
is is gradient descent so there you're
given at each cause at each time static
you you know you you're given the cost
function you know and you you pay your
cost and then you want to update based
on on the cost function you just saw and
so what you do is you take your gradient
to the current parameter value and you
update it you add some multiple of that
to your current parameter so you sort of
take a little step as if playing
gradient you know gradient descent but
with respect to the cost function you
just saw and if necessary you project
yourself back into the set that you're
allowed to play very different
very different type of algorithm is
something called follow the perturb
leader so this is something that is
specific to learning with experts at
least as I'll state it so here the again
my convex said is the set of
distributions over the labels of the
experts of which there are D my cost
functions are linear because it's you
know I'm just pay I'm paying for the
inner product between W&F so at each
time step again i get i receive a
sequence of numbers between 0 and 1 i
pay what i have to pay and then the way
I do my update is I'm going to define a
distribution I'm going to define this
random variable vector valued random
variable i'm going to add up all the
costs vectors i've seen so far i'll add
random noise to each of those things and
i'll pick the one that minimizes that
has the minimum minimal noisy cost ok so
this is I'm you know intentionally
phrasing this algorithm in a way that
makes it look like basically the
exponential mechanism or the you know
simple where was this easier to
implement version of the exponential
mechanism and this is you know this is
this is follow the perturbed leader or
one but one of the versions of it I
believe this version was proposed by
client impala but don't get too don't
take me too seriously when it comes to
references in the online literature
learning literature yeah so these are
these are to like you know prototypical
types of algorithms a lot of the
algorithms that are actually used sort
of fall into you smell like one of these
two all right
okay so what about privacy so so what
we're going to do in this talk I'm just
going to look at designing I'm not going
to look at the kind of more
sophisticated type of transformation
that John was talking about this morning
here we're just looking at designing
differentially private designing online
learning algorithms that are
differentially private right so I'm
going to think of that the data at each
step is belonging to some person and
what I want is that essentially what i
want is is that the entire vector of
outputs of my algorithm be
differentially private the entire not
vector but list of parameter vectors be
differentially private so this
corresponds to what a dork nor petoskey
and rose bloom called event level
differential privacy under continual
observation we think of an adversary is
picking two adjacent input streams X and
X Prime they differ in one data point or
one cost function and then there you
know I'm going to look at the
distribution on the two output streams
and I'm going to require that those
distributions be epsilon Delta close
okay in fact this is not quite the
definition you need what you really need
is an adaptive version of the definition
where the adversary can sort of choose
the stream online based on the things
you've said so far and it turns out
those definitions are like slightly
different but not in ways that matter
for today okay and just one useful thing
to know is that there's one algorithm
for this model this model up here that
well it's actually private in both
models and that that comes up a lot in
these sort of continual observation
settings and and we're going to use it
too so basically it's an algorithm for
evaluating prefects sums so imagine that
I've got you know the input is a stream
of vectors real vectors and I want to
approximate all the partial sums then
what I get is what basically there's a
there's some tree binary tree based
algorithm that gives me a pretty good
approximation to each of the sums and
with a sort of a poly log error and
dependency on the dimension that's
missing so this is should be the
diameter times the dimension is yeah
well ok so the l1 error it does it
doesn't really matter here the l1 error
is scales logarithmically or poly
logarithmically with t and and there's
there's another term of the dimension
that I admit it but this algorithm is a
is epsilon differentially private in in
both models okay so this is our notion
of privacy so we want to design now
online learning algorithms that that
satisfy this this notion of privacy so
how hard is it to do this right so some
algorithms actually just kind of look
naturally differentially private so this
follow the perturbed leader that I'd
find two slides ago as I said you know
you can think of it as basically
implementing the exponential mechanism
and so it is it does give you some kind
of privacy at least if I just look at
one output at a time rather the entire
vector of outputs okay and so there's
still some thinking that goes in in
there on the other hand some algorithms
are much harder to analyze for example
this gradient descent algorithm it's not
quite as obvious how you should think
about it in terms of privacy because you
know the the choices I make early on in
the algorithm have some weird effect for
the rest of time and so it's not
entirely clear how you bound the effect
of one term on everything that comes
later okay so what I'll I'll try to do
in this talk is to give you some
algorithms for private online learning
and I'll try and you know highlight the
connection to stability and so you know
this is also this sort of an outline
i'll talk about forward stability and I
sort of regret in this kind of modified
model where I got to look see the future
will call this the crystal ball regret
and then a couple of so we'll sort of
set up a framework for analyzing these
algorithms then look at a couple
different ways of sort of filling in the
blanks in that framework in just a few
notes there are very almost no citations
in this talk to the ideas we're using
from the online learning literature so
that's unfair but I realized that I
didn't have time to do the research to
put exactly the right
citations in and I'd rather I just I
don't want to be wrong and the other
note i'll just make is that John Gucci
or Dukey how it's the correct way to
pronounce your last name gucci will give
a talk tomorrow on results that that
have a similar flavor for what's called
the local model and you know we'll hear
about that tomorrow okay so what do we
know about what are the results that are
known on differentially private online
learning well for the prediction from
expert experts problem you can get you
know a couple of different results
depending on how you kind of use this
this basic follow the perturb leader
algorithm one of them is from you know
due to dork north tustin roth bloom and
the other in fact an observation one can
lick one she can show this is due to
conversations with opera deep is that in
fact the original kalai impala algorithm
already gives you some non-trivial with
if you just set the parameters correctly
already gives you a non-trivial
differentially private learning
algorithm with a good dependency on the
dimension d better dependency on the
dimension d one can get algorithms for
convex functions for general convex
functions under a smoothness condition
under assuming they're Lipschitz get
something like square root of T times
square root of T dependency if you
assume they're strong these functions
are strongly convex you get much better
types of guarantees something like
logarithmic and a recent result is that
you can also get an online approximation
for you know a very non convex problem
which is finding a singular like rank a
approximation the right singular vector
space with with against um you know
dependency that's something like square
root of T times some load small
polynomial in the dimension and that's
work due to dork Paul worth a quarter
and Jang that I guess we'll hear some
more about tomorrow or Saturday oh and
one thing I'll mention is these are all
in a sort of worst-case model is this is
this kind of adversarial model you
turns out you can get much much better
analyses if you're making stochastic
assumptions and I'm not going to talk
about that okay there's a variant of
this basic model that I've described
which is called the Bandit setting or
the partial information setting where
the algorithm doesn't actually learn the
full cost function at each phase what it
learns is only the cost that it paid
right so if you don't go to the other
investment advisors and you don't go you
know work with them then you don't know
how much their you you know return you
would have gotten on your investment
with them right you only learn the money
you actually lost and it turns out that
setting is very different you can read
about it in the paper I'm not going to
talk about it more so we're going to
stick to the full information setting
because it's much simpler and basically
all the ideas i'm going to discuss those
are the ideas that we can use in the
Bandit setting their the the mate the
main main ideas are the same there sorry
okay so this is again the talk outline
so let's talk about forward stability
and you know are a little crystal ball
okay so just some background is this you
know one thing you might want to do is
called follow the leader and in fact
it's a surprising surprisingly it's not
a terrible idea so follow the leader
says I look at everything I've seen in
the past all my cost functions that I've
seen so far and I'm just going to make
at each step I'm just going to play the
strategy that would have served me best
in hindsight okay so in general in
general this is actually an awful idea
right and and that's because you're sort
of always fighting the last war right so
this algorithm can be made to kind of
thrash around in horrible ways and if
you you set up your input adversarial e
then this can have you know very high
regret Omega of n but but it's
nonetheless it's still the basis of most
of the online learning and algorithms
that are out there and you might wonder
why and yeah the sort of
counterintuitive answer is that actually
follow the leader would be a great idea
if hindsight included a little bit of
the future right if you could actually
sort of see what's coming up next and
and and make your make your decision
against knowing you know the cost the
cost you'll actually be paying um so we
you know let's just consider for a while
a slightly different model so here's our
original model where we pay for the you
know I make a prediction i see a cost
function and i pay okay so let's imagine
a different model where you know I see a
cost function I make a prediction and
then I pay right and I pay for the I pay
for the previous times you know I pay
for the previous cost function not the
next one okay so you know we'd all life
love to live in this world right I
certainly would Ivan Lee had caused her
you know regret decisions but surprise
you know yes somewhat surprisingly it's
actually it's actually you know useful
to imagine living in this world and
think about things this way so so let's
call the crystal ball regret also called
the forward regret let's call that the
cost i'd pay in this sort of crystal
ball model where I get to see the
future- as before the best the best
choice I would make in hindsight over
the entire run of the algorithm okay so
the the beginning observation is that
the fault the basic follow-the-leader
algorithm actually has you know crystal
ball regret that's at mo 0 right like
I'll never actually regret my decisions
in that model okay and you know maybe
that's not surprising is because that
you know I get to see the future okay
but how can we use that well well
suppose I have this promise that somehow
my my parameter predictions I suppose I
have a promise that I've got an
algorithm at a has low crystal ball
regret and furthermore it's my
predictions I make it each time step
don't change too quickly okay so if the
predictions I make at each time step
don't change too quickly then in fact my
true regret really is close to this
crystal ball regret right and so this
motor
let's let's sort of formulated another
condition which will call stability and
stability is just you know the sum over
all time steps of the difference between
the cost i pay in the crystal ball model
and the cost i pay in real life right
and the idea is if each of these pairs
is closed then each of these terms will
be small and you know maybe that'll buy
me something okay this forward stability
is also called the online stability i
guess we're some you know variations on
this are called online stability there
are a number of variants of this
definition out there okay and and then
the useful fact which is sort of obvious
from the definitions is that the regret
is equal to the you know the forward
stability plus the regret in the crystal
ball model and so I just want to bound
each of these two all right so that
gives us a basic a basic setup and we're
gonna and again there's nothing new here
so pretty much this this is the way that
online learning algorithms are designed
in the sort of non private setting or at
least the way they're analyzed and but
we're going to try to use this way of
thinking about it to to get
differentially private algorithms all
right so so we need two things we need
to bound this sort of crystal ball
regret and we need to bound our forwards
stability so to bat for stability we
need as it said to show that the cost i
pay when i see the future is sort of the
same roughly as the cost i pay when I
you know in real life and and and we'll
see there is how they're really like two
different very different ways to
actually approach this okay so one is to
use sort of statistical closeness okay
so use to look for for wnw t plus 1 that
are somehow close in distribution so no
so suppose I just go design a
differentially private algorithm right
and then I hope it has good online
regret well what I know is if the out if
the algorithm that produces WT that
produces each you know each of my
outputs if it is itself differentially
private epsilon T differentially private
and the distributions on WT and WT plus
1 R epsilon T closed and so the the
stability of the outer the sort of
difference between real life and the
crystal ball model is the most the sum
of these epsilon well x times something
which is like the maximum you know you
have to scale it according to how big
your costs can be right so the maximum
cost you could have paid on anyone at
any one time step okay and this is just
this is just like a statistical distance
argument so this isn't exactly the sum
of the epsilon zits like e to the
epsilon minus 1 alternatively you could
go by a closeness in norm okay so rather
than asking the distributions on WT and
WT plus wanted to be close you might
just ask that they be actually like
close as vectors right and the second
that so the way these analyses proceed
is that i'll assume lrl elope or ensure
somehow that my individual cost
functions are are not merely convex but
but strongly convex you know meaning
they have some real curvature with
respect to some norm and then I can
ensure that that that norm of WT minus
WT plus 1 is small and then as long as
my functions are also smooth meaning
they don't change too quickly then the
stability i get is roughly going to be
the sum of the distances bounded above
by the sum of the distances from WTH at
WT plus 1 and as long as that sum is not
too problematically large than i'm in
i'm in good shape right so this sort of
tells me this this this kind of analysis
tells me how much does my parameter
vector wander around what's a total
distance it traveled over the course of
the algorithm right and so what it says
if you think really slowly in fact you
know maybe just making the best
prediction in hindsight isn't a bad
thing because you know you're pretty
much going to be competitive with the
future all right and then so this will
this doesn't know this doesn't talk
about privacy but it tells us that we
already have some sort of stability
property built in and then we can sort
of also get differential privacy if
we're careful and then so that tells us
how to but you know
sort of the basic ways to think about
forward stability and to bound the kind
of crystal ball regret it turns out use
the same idea in all of these cases and
and what what you do is you you you
think about your out you so your
algorithms not actually running follow
the leader in general but what you try
to argue is that it's actually running
follow the leader with respect to some
other sequence of cost functions not
your true cost functions but something
else and that other sequence of cost
functions is somehow close enough to the
things you are after that that the the
crystal ball regret is small so this is
sort of this is kind of the as i said
the generic blueprint in its two and
it's two variants that are a bit that
are out there and for the time I have
left I guess I which is not much I'll
tell you a bit more about each of those
how much time do I have another five
minutes all right okay so that was just
my outline again so let's just talk
about strong convexity so a function is
Lipschitz with respect to some norm if
the difference in the function is
bounded by L times the norm of the norm
of difference between the arguments and
that's that's a very natural definition
strong convexity slightly may be
slightly less standard is if i can i can
think so so i can think of convexity as
giving me this convexity is the
statement that that a given function can
be bounded below by if I've got some
function i can always be i can take any
point and i draw the tangent to that
point and that gives me a lower bound on
the function that's the definition of
convexity so strong convexity is the
definite is the condition that i can
bound it by a quadratic function okay
with some non zero curvature and Sigma
is that you know the parameters the
strong convexity is how curve that
quadratic is okay and a basic basic
lemma is that if F is Sigma if I've got
some function that's Sigma strongly come
back
and some little function you know little
F that's L lip [ __ ] and I look at the
different the two minimizer is one for
big app and one for big f plus little F
then those two minute those two
minimizer's are going to be close okay
and they're off by at most l over Sigma
so this lemma comes up I don't think it
I mean I made up the name convex
stability limit it comes up all the time
I don't think it normally gets the name
okay so why is that why is that lemming
useful well suppose that I've got a
bunch of funk cost functions that are
all strongly convex okay then I will use
this stability limit to argue that in
fact the the fault of the follow the
leader has has a low regret okay and so
that gives us a lower it's a standard
way to get a low regret algorithm the
problem is that just sort of adding
privacy to follow the leader directly
doesn't work very well it costs us a lot
in accuracy so instead we'll use will
sort of modify the follow the leader
argument or modify the algorithm to use
it an idea called either dual averaging
or basically a mirror which is basically
the same thing as mayor descent to
express this sort of follow the leader
algorithm in terms of prefects some
queries on the data stream and then we
can use our standard algorithms for for
perfect some to get a differentially
private version okay so why is it that
it has low so I claim that once when
everything strongly convex follow the
leader itself is a good idea it has very
low regret and the point is that so we
know that it's wait I wrote the wrong
thing here what we know is that it's
crystal ball regret is that most zero
what we want to argue is that for its
forward stability is bounded okay so we
want to just so by that this if if each
of the little cost functions is eight
strongly convex then at time T
cost function I'm minimizing which is
the sum of all of them it's you know HT
strongly convex and so the difference
between WT and WT plus one is l / HT by
this stability limit and because my
function is lip [ __ ] because my cost
functions are also Lipschitz what I know
is that the actual difference in the
cost function is at most you know it
multiplies by at most L so that's l
squared over H tea and then if I add
this up over over time so again sorry
this should be stability i don't know
wherever CBR if I just add up over all
time steps how much I've paid its l
squared over H times the harmonic series
and so that's about you know log of T
okay sort up and I just one note is if
the FIS are not strongly convex turns
out you what you can do is just add in a
small strongly convex function and if
you sort of do it just right this will
give you a non-trivial the weaker bounds
you'll get I'm not going to discuss that
okay so this gives us a non-private
algorithm it also gives us a sensitivity
analysis that I won't go through
basically that was what was used in the
work of Jane kothari and Thakur otha you
sort of you need one more idea to get it
to get really good regret here though so
the sort of just using Laplace noise and
a straightforward sense sensitivity
analysis will give you something like
quadratic regret and you can get a lot
better by using this idea that the this
this strongly convex function it can all
you can always lower bound it by this
these quadratic terms right and so what
you do is you actually run your
algorithm or you analyze your algorithm
not with respect to the original cost
functions but with respect to some
quadratic approximation of those cost
functions and what you'll do is at any
given point V you can develop this
quadratic approximation it's just you
know sort of basically like a Taylor
expansion you take the gradient times WV
that's the linear component and then
this quadratic component
and what we get is that this this
function equals so f tilde equals f @ v
and in general it's always a lower bound
for f and a a key idea which which comes
from the comes from the online learning
literature is that for any algorithm
instead of measuring regret with respect
to the real cost functions I can regret
with respect to these approximations as
long as they i define them at the right
places as long as they define them at
exactly the points i actually predict
try to predict and this gives us so so
instead of using the real cost function
i use this sort of proxy function and it
turns out that that gives us a you know
an algorithm that has exactly the same
regret behavior as the regular
follow-the-leader algorithm but it's
going to be much easier to make it
private and the reason is that well so
there actually a couple of reasons why
you might want to do this I should
mention one is speed it turns out that
in many cases this this algorithm can be
rewritten in a form that you can run
much more quickly so it can for example
in if you're using the l2 norm you
basically this this algorithm is
equivalent to the usual online gradient
descent that algorithm I gave you at the
beginning of the talk and for in other
norms you can do a similar derivation
but actually the real reason I want this
to use this algorithm is because what it
tells me is that the decisions I make at
some time later time in the algorithm
they depend on a very concise summary of
what I've seen so far so they depend
only on the sum of the gradients the
only way the only place the data comes
into my function that I'm minimizing at
each time step is via the sum of the
gradients that I've observed so far okay
and so by putting it in that form I
managed to you know you can add noise to
that those those prefects sums and you
get a much better a much much better
type of guarantee and that's how you get
this guarantee of the form D of R
epsilon times Polly logarithmic and T
so that covers sort of these algorithms
here and here these algorithms out here
they followed by a different analysis
the first and the last and since I'm out
of time I won't go through it in any
detail but the basic idea is really just
what I said that that differential
privacy already gives us some stability
we can just like use that stability to
get a non-trivial regret mount
unfortunately this case we what you get
is epsilon Delta privacy only you don't
get epsilon privacy epsilon zero privacy
I won't go through it but it I mean it's
very straightforward all right so that
so I tried to give you a like a concise
summary of how online learning
algorithms can be differentially private
online learning algorithms can be
defined and designed rather their their
number of open questions so in general
the dependency on the dimension of these
algorithms is quite poor okay so there's
an exception which is the disc alive and
Paula follow the preserve leader
algorithm has logarithmic dependency on
the dimension but the other is all
because they're all based on noise
addition they basically incur a large
caught a bad dependency on that mention
you know another the I didn't go into
the results in the Bandit setting but so
one thing I should mention is that in
the full information setting most of the
algorithms I gave you they nearly match
the best non-private bounce so up to a
factor of about 1 over epsilon in
general okays or D over epsilon in some
cases and so you could in principle get
much much tighter bounce in a bandit
setting the gaps are quite a bit bigger
their polynomial a large and the last
question I'll you know I'll throw out
there which I don't have a good answer
to is whether or not these techniques in
particular this sort of linearization
idea gives us any insight into you know
heart Roth bloom style private
multiplicative weights algorithms you
know I tried thinking about this I don't
think it really gave us you have
anything new but you know who knows and
then you know one other thing I'll
mention is you can imagine stronger
notions of privacy such as
privacy that was defined in a paper of
dork at all and and Sasha will talk
about it okay so one could hope one
might hope that these would give us new
pan private albums and I'm not sure all
right I'll stop there thanks right so so
I'm not sure exactly so this is a such
as this is your laptop right did you
want it so if it's what I think you're
talking about it's in the Bandit setting
this is a horrible suggested names just
like class so yeah then I don't know I'm
not sure whatever look what you thought
about regularized I mean follow the
regular eyes leader of that right so so
actually what I mean we use that in this
talk although I didn't say it explicitly
so so when you when you went the way I
said you go for a deal with general non
strongly convex convex functions is you
add a term to them that makes them
strongly convex that's a regularizer and
that gives you you know if you choose a
regularizer correctly that gives you a
non-trivial regret bounds okay and it
doesn't hurt your privacy much how to
use the funky regular risers that come
up in more recent work out insurance so
this is a very simple regularization
strategy one can imagine this room for
much more sophisticated one yeah huh
so I'm not sure about so so in the Jane
kothari attack earth of paper they
discuss they discuss using the local
model so one big difference is that it
there's a big difference whether or not
you're looking at stochastic that's like
iid data or worse or worst case okay so
all these algorithms have much better
guarantees in the stochastic setting
although i can't i can't like rattle
them off the top of my head what they
are so if I've had to guess off the top
in my head my guess is that the bounds
you have in mind or for this to cast the
static askim all but i'm not sure okay
all right well maybe yeah it's oh yes so
separating the models with the
interesting certainly these albums are
not as presented or not you know local
right I don't know yeah I don't other
questions or shut up you know I'll take
the other questions offline what
promotes that